waren sehr kurz eineinhalb stunden kann
man sagen die erste tv debatte trump
gegen beiden wir haben hier zusammen
geschaut im studio professorin sabine c
amerikanistik von der uni bonn ist immer
noch bei uns und auch ihre kirschbaum
hat durchgehalten von der los angeles
times
sie haben anfangs mit dem kopf
geschüttelt als das los ging herr
kirschbaum und sie sagten so was in der
art wie es sieht irgendwie gerade nicht
so gut aus für beide jetzt nach den
anderthalb stunden wie ist ihr eindruck
ja das war ein schlag schlamm schlag
sondergleichen das hat man noch nie
gesehen in den usa das war teilweise
unterhalten aber teilweise der premiere
in das ist so ein niedriges niveau hatte
und mit der ständige unterbrechung von
trump das war seine strategie beiden zu
beunruhigen
auf glatteis zu führen aber wo man lacht
manchmal ist es deprimierend das zeigt
die ganze polarisierung in der märkte
die das die vier jahren
es zeigt wie spart gespalten das land
ist und dass die einander kaum ein
anderer gebeten haben lassen es heute
probieren wirklich das war ein bisschen
die kinder gehalten
schwer zu glauben dass diese zwei männer
präsident werden sollen was wirklich
kein sternstunde für merkel ein bisschen
peinlich dass die welt sieht wie
niveaulos das teilweise geworden biden
hat schon beim klauen genannt und holz
mauer gesagt ich meine die dinge die
kann man gar nicht vorstellen dass man
das wirklich gehört hat in seinem gebet
sie haben es jetzt mal bei beiden
beispiele genannt trump war natürlich
auch nicht schlecht er hat sich ja
permanent eingemischt und ihn auch der
der falschaussage bezichtigt gegen
djokovic ist meine stadt gewöhnt ist
diese parole aus wir aber dass er gleich
von anfang an beinahe taktiert hat hat
beiden kaum reden lassen am anfang man
hat gesehen in der moto beiden beiden
wirklich beunruhigen und
in diese in dieser bestätigung dass der
schläfrige joe ist es war wirklich
wirklich deprimierend muss ich sagen
dass in der ak nö kann man gar nicht
stolz zeigen aktuelle duell
sie haben festgestellt beiden hat sich
gewehrt leidlich frau professorin silke
wollte er oder hat er es geschafft
diesem image des repeaters oder das
abzuschütteln
also grundsätzlich denke ich auch es war
genau der schlagabtausch den mann so
erwartet hat inhaltlich nichts neues
ich denke dass beiden an den punkten wo
ihnen dann kramt mal nicht unterbrochen
hat sozusagen ihr charisma und da ist er
konnte er darstellen dass die demokraten
eine andere politik verfolgen
auch da sicherlich nichts neues für den
zuhörer aber dabei wurde deutlich wie er
sich im profil auch unterscheidet und in
der selbstdarstellung unterscheidet
nämlich dass er den wähler anspricht
dass er sich als empathisch gibt dass er
auch eben die angriffsfläche die tram
bietet durchaus nutzen kann und
gleichzeitig seine wir unwahrheiten
wiederholt die wir kennen die fact
checker werden wahrscheinlich unterwegs
sein und das machen wir prüfen aber das
kennen wir auch alles schon
gleichzeitig wirkt beiden natürlich
fragiler und das hat auch sehr damit zu
tun wie die beiden herren sich gerieren
das hat mit körpersprache zu tun deshalb
mit stimme zu tun und da wirkt beiden
eben tatsächlich älter aber letzte beide
sind in den 70ern und das will scheinbar
das amerikanische volk diese älteren
herren die sozusagen jetzt
in der letzten runde sind körpersprache
haben sie angesprungen
vielleicht können wir da noch mal
genauer darauf eingehen man konnte sehen
dass die beiden tatsächlich dann
probleme hatte sich zu konzentrieren
wenn er permanent von trump unterbrochen
wurde das war die taktik was gibt es
sonst noch zu sagen konkret zur zur
körpersprache was haben sie beobachtet
ja ich glaube trump ist offensichtlich
jemand der sich breiter aufstellt im
wahrsten sinne des wortes und eben auch
gleichzeitig eben austeilt und das auch
körperlich aus teilt er sah ich war so
ein bisschen erinnert an die an die
erste debatte zwischen nixon und john
kennedy obwohl die so anders war und man
wünscht sich das was wieder zurück die
disziplin aber er war braungebrannt
während während beiden eben etwas
blässlich aussah das sind alles dinge
die natürlich mit spielen und insofern
ist es schwierig zu sagen werden nun der
sieger dieses schlagabtausches ist ewig
sie hat das ganze auch wie ein boxkampf
beworben es war sicherlich auch so was
gleichzeitig glaube ich haben wir auch
zwei verschiedene programme gesehen
ich habe beobachtet joe biden hat
versuchte mehr in die kamera zu schauen
also mehr so da das publikum direkt zu
adressieren wohingegen trump schon auch
deutlich immer in beiden richtung sprach
und sich ihm im zugewandt habe zwar
steckt aber hinter für eine strategie
biden will die paar millionen wähler
erreichen die noch nicht entschieden
haben er hat es probiert manchmal weg
von dieser ganze duell direkt in die
kamera sondern wie viele das sind die
tatsächlich noch mal in ihrer existenz
aber das sind wichtige wären auch haie
und flora in dieses swing states das
sind die wichtige wäre beiden wollten
direkt mit dem rating wurde weg für ein
bisschen wegkommen von dieser zirkus was
da stattgefunden hat und er probiert
direkt in die kamera
beiden war anscheinend gut vorbereitet
chance sagt der markt gar keine
vorbereitungen schon ledert einfach los
mit seiner sprüche und polen aber beiden
war gut vorbereitet er wusste
ein paar millionen leute vielleicht doch
erreichen und das war sein das war ihm
wichtig aber beiden immer wieder die
augen zugemacht wenn schon in den bach
runter schaut wirklich nicht gut aus und
ich kann mir vorstellen in die
wiederholungen und die ganze nachrichten
nach arbeit und man wird immer wieder
sehen wie beiden die augen zumacht und
und nicht so glücklich ausschaut werden
mit sehr viel zutrauen einfach loslegen
sie ja immer nur ums leben die bilder
die bilder die nach dieser diät immer
wieder in den nachrichten gezeigt werden
permanent die nächste tage ich weiß
nicht ob die vermeiden so gut ausschauen
werden bevor ich hatte wichtiger gute
dinge gesagt er war wirklich fette weil
gar nicht so schläfrig aber die augen
uhr wieder zu so machen er hat gesagt
jetzt die 20 30 malen wohl einfach
kommen was ein kleiner nächsten stadt
darüber zu reden aber ja es war ja ganz
wie wir erwartet haben unterhaltsam das
war die erste von drei und ich freue
mich auf die nächste zweite bild genau
werden wir in der zweiten runde dann
nochmal über die inhaltlichen punkte
jetzt sprechen
bis dahin erst mal vielen dank denn wir
wollen jetzt schalten nochmal nach
cleveland elmar theveßen es da immer sie
haben die debatte natürlich verfolgt
viele themen hat es gegeben viele
unterbrechungen viele beschuldigungen
auch beschimpfungen was bleibt jetzt
hängen von dieser ersten debatte jahres
hauptrede thema werden natürlich diese
beschimpfungen seien und zwar von beiden
seiten in erster linie natürlich von
donald trump aber eben auch von joe
biden der den präsidenten einen clown
genannt hat diese schlagabtausche die
werden sicherlich bei den zuschauern 100
millionen sind es möglicherweise in den
usa gewesen
dazu führen dass sie sich fragen sind
denn der eine oder der andere wirklich
geeignet präsident zu sein
es war ich sage es ganz ehrlich dass
meine persönliche meinung so ziemlich
die würdelose debatte die ich in den
letzten jahrzehnten verfolgt habe hier
in den usa
gleichzeitig aber muss man sagen dass
auch eine menge inhaltlich drin steckte
was ein bisschen überlagert worden ist
durch diesen streit
man hat viel gehört von plänen für die
zukunft von joe biden wenig dazu von
donald trump er war mehr damit
beschäftigt die vergangenheit die
letzten vier jahre zu
reinigen und joe biden hat zum ende hin
ja den punkt gemacht wenn man sich
überlegt was diese letzten vier jahre
waren so behauptet er jedenfalls dann
ist amerika schwächer amerika ist ärmer
amerikas kranker amerika ist mehr
geteilt mehr polarisiert und auch ein
stück weit mehr gewalt gibt es im land
und vor diesem hintergrund stellte er
die frage ob man vier weitere jahre von
lügen haben will wie man sie von donald
trump gehört hat diesen punkt wollte joe
biden sicherlich machen
ich glaube nur dass er doch weit
überdeckt worden ist von diesen
streitereien in dieser debatte die das
muss man noch mal sagen nicht alleine
von trump ausgingen sondern auch von joe
biden und insofern muss man sehen wie
sich das auf die meinungsumfragen in den
nächsten tagen auswirken wird
einen blick in die sozialen medien zeigt
herrscht activate 2020 endet weltweit
joe biden endet bei twitter mit dem
zitat ja will you just shut up man auch
nicht unbedingt sehr rühmlich und der
moderator aber chris wallace er wird
kritisiert es wird gesagt er hatte die
debatte nicht so gut im griff weil es
eben zu diesen vielen unterbrechungen
gekommen ist und weil sehr viele themen
kurz angerissen wurden die beiden dann
aber immer abgeschlossen sind das war
sicherlich auch kein leichter job was
war ihr eindruck dahingehend ja ich
glaube chris wallace hat eigentlich das
gemacht was er machen musste immer
wieder versucht die beiden auf das thema
zurück zu bringen und kritische
nachfragen gestellt
ich sage ganz ehrlich ich würde den
moderator gern mal sehen wollen der es
schafft einen präsidenten der sich fest
vorgenommen hat im grunde genommen
dieses debatten format zu dem er selber
zugestimmt hatte vorher der regel recht
zu sprengen
und ich glaube wenn man die debatte sich
noch einmal anschaut wird man sehen dass
dies vor allen dingen von denen schon
begonnen worden ist etwas später hat
sich dann auch joe biden dazu hinreißen
lassen immer weiter zu unterbrechen
wichtig sind aber doch einige punkte die
man noch mal festhalten muss also man
hat ganz klar gesehen dass in sachen
wirtschaft beide für sich in anspruch
nehmen dass sie gezeigt haben in der
vergangenheit dass sie die wirtschaft
wieder ans laufen bekommen können und
die amerikaner für die ist das
eigentlich das allerwichtigste thema die
wirtschaft der
unmittelbare job die eigene perspektive
die man hat am ende lässt sich schwer
sagen wir da diese debatte gewonnen hat
für mich ist noch hängen geblieben die
frage distanzierung von gewalt das ist
ja ein wahlkampf der sich vor allen
dingen um angst dreht jede seite macht
angst vor der anderen seite
und da hat joe biden sehr klar und sehr
eindeutig distanziert von der gewalt hat
ganz klar gesagt dass eine sind
friedliche proteste und demonstranten
und das andere sind gewalttäter die
dafür eben auch straff verfolgt werden
müssen
er ist gegen jede art von gewalt hat
auch ganz klar gesagt dass er glaubt
dass polizei nicht abgeschafft werden
sollte sondern man sollte sie
reformieren ihr bessere werkzeuge an die
hand geben
da unterscheidet er sich deutlich von
dem was donald trump ihm vorwirft
nämlich dass er die polizei abschaffen
will und auf der anderen seite und das
ist glaube ich auch etwas was nach wirkt
hat donald trump sich geweigert sich von
weißen rassisten und auch von weißen
rechtsextremisten ganz klar und
eindeutig zu distanzieren da hätte die
chance gehabt er wurde gefragt von chris
wallace und er hat an diesem punkt
gesagt die sollen jetzt einen im grunde
um sich zurückhaltend stand da und so
hat er es gesagt entstand bei so als
sollten sie sich doch bereithalten für
was auch immer und vor dem hintergrund
muss man sich schon ein stück weit
sorgen machen wenn die wahl nicht zu
einem klaren ergebnis führt was dann in
den wochen und monaten danach hier in
den usa geschehen könnte einmal wenn ich
sie richtig verstanden habe inhaltlich
hat beiden ein paar mehr punkte gut
gemacht aber in der performance liegt
der punkt er bei trump könnte man es so
zusammenfassen
nein ich glaube die performance war für
beide eigentlich schlecht weil sie sich
gegenseitig ins wort gefallen sind und
sich gegenseitig beschimpft haben also
der stil noch mal lässt so den eindruck
zurück ist der joe biden geeignet
präsident zu sein ist donald trump
geeignet präsident zu sein oder würde
man sich vielleicht lieber jemand ganz
anderen wünschen aber inhaltlich das
glaube ich kann man sehr klar sagen hat
joe biden sehr gepunktet weil er an
vielen stellen wirklich gesagt hat was
er vorhat in den nächsten vier jahren da
ist donald trump eigentlich alles
schuldig geblieben
keine neuen plänen keine neuen vorhaben
angekündigt auch nicht als antwort auf
das was schon beiden gesagt hat und das
ist vielleicht die größte schwäche von
donald trump weil für die menschen auch
ein stück bei zählt jedenfalls für die
die veränderungen in den usa wollen ein
stück weit zählt ob ein präsident einen
plan hat
und da bleibt vielleicht auch der satz
von joe biden hängen dieser mann hat
keinen plan
den haben wir mehrfach gehört vielen
dank elmar theveßen für ihre ersten
einschätzungen aus cleveland und wir
sind wieder zurück im studio wir haben
ja gesagt wir wollen ein bisschen
inhaltlich er einsteigen
es fing an eigentlich ging es ums thema
supreme court dann ist das aber relativ
schnell abgeschliffen und sie haben sich
beide recht stark an obamacare irgendwo
festgebissen und auch regelrecht
gestritten warum ist das eigentlich
immer noch so ein wunder punkt ja wo die
republikaner wollten seit jahren das
abschaffen dann haben die mehrheiten
gehabt dann haben sie nicht geschafft
und deswegen die republikaner sind ein
bisschen zerstritten was machen die
damit aber obamacare und ist eine ganz
wichtige thema für millionen von
amerikaner 20.30 mehreren leute haben
dann krankenversicherung kommen dass die
vorher nicht hatten das muss man in
deutschland vorstellen dass ein
millionen von leute haben gar keine
krankenversicherung ist auch ein grund
warum ich gerne in deutschland wohnen
wollte ich das hier erlebt habe und
durch obama haben 30 40 millionen leute
plötzlich krankenversicherung was die
folge schatten und dann wurden die
republikaner das abbauen nur weil das so
war maßnahme hat und die haben das nicht
geschafft
deswegen es ist noch ein wahlkampfthema
in manchen bundesstaaten wo demokraten
blaue bundesstaaten da gibt es obama
weiterhin und es wird ausgebaut
andere bundesstaaten republikanische das
wird abgebaut und es ist ist es nach wie
vor ein wichtiges thema für beide
parteien planen supreme court die
nominierte noch ist sie nicht bestätigt
aber nachfolgerin emi kunibert hat sich
auch eindeutig gegen obama klar
positioniert wenn sie also da jetzt
das oberste amerikanische gericht kommt
dann befürchten viele demokraten dass
damit im jahren im grundstein gelegt ist
auch tatsächlich für eine änderung der
verfassung für eine verfassungsänderung
wir haben sechs zu drei dann juristen
republikaner gegen liberale oder oder
gemischt mit mit liberalen was sagt das
denn insgesamt aus über die verfassung
des landes also was deutlich wird ist
dass die amerikanische demokratie die
auf der verfassung fuße den bau ist und
mit der neuen nominierten juristin ist
natürlich jemand da die die verfassung
auslegen will im wortwörtlichen sinne
also nicht von einer living constitucion
redet wie viele andere juristen
sie ist sehr dehnbar gleichzeitig denke
ich selbst wenn die nominierung noch vor
der wahl passiert ist nicht klar wie der
supreme court entscheiden wird er hat in
den letzten monaten auch entscheidungen
getroffen die chance da waren die tasten
geringer und diese liberal scheinen also
ich glaube auch ein konservativer
supreme court wird vielleicht besonders
darauf achten müssen
die verfassung zu achten und eben auch
die demokratie in den usa zu erhalten
wie sie wie sie eben ist aber was wir
wirklich sehen im moment ist das dass
die demokratie in den usa so dehnbar ist
und dass vieles zu zugelassen wird oder
vieles möglich ist was eigentlich eine
demokratie vielleicht auch nicht würdig
ist ja viele sprechen von einer
regelrechten bewährungsprobe für die
amerikanische demokratie würden sie das
so unterstützen ja die hat sie
eigentlich immer gehabt denn sie hat
einen schlechten start gehabt sie war
widersprüchlich von anbeginn diese
kultur ist paradox das liegt schon an
den grundstein
der sklaverei in einen demokratischen in
einer demokratischen nation
also das ist glaube ich auch das was die
losung was diese kultur so interessant
macht und wir stehen da und es ist eben
polit entertainment man kann froh sein
dass diese debatte wahrscheinlich nicht
viel bewirken wird wie wir wissen sind
die debatten jetzt nicht ausschlaggebend
unbedingt für wähler entscheidung
wichtig ist und das hat ja auch beiden
immer wieder versucht zu betonen dass
menschen von ihrem wahlrecht gebrauch
machen und sich dieses wahlrecht nicht
entziehen lassen was ja offensichtlich
auch möglich ist wie wir jetzt
deutlicher sehen als zu jeder wahl in
den letzten dekaden wie das wahlrecht
eigentlich geregelt ist oder eben nicht
geregelt ist in einem vom wahlrecht
gebrauch machen das ist ja auch noch mal
gegen ende der debatte ein ja strittiges
thema gewesen nämlich stichwort
briefwahl in einigen staaten können die
bürger auch schon persönlich wählen aber
dann gibt es eben das große thema
briefwahl vovo tram nach wie vor sagt er
sie hätte selber gesehen
wie also unterlagen vernichtet oder
weggeschmissen würden und er zweifelt
also da sozusagen die glaubwürdigkeit
der wahl an
erste frage wie schätzen sie das ein und
zweite frage wenn es ein knappes
wahlergebnis werden sollte was denken
sie wird trump dann eine niederlage
eingestehen
ja so seine frage zuerst ich glaube
schon ich glaube die institutionen den
usa sind so ausgelegt dass alle
institutionen bilden das akzeptiere das
wahlergebnis
die militär die des senates das ist
manchmal ein bisschen hochgepuscht in
den medien von europa glaubt die meisten
leute rechnen schon damit dass das
ergebnis wird gezählt und das wird
entschieden oder ein bleibt oder geht
aber das ist dass das ist so ein beiname
publik lager wert glaube ich nicht und
ich glaube nicht so viele leute glauben
dass und mit dem brief waren und zweifel
so ziehen in den in dem prozess ist eine
automatische der republikaner die
republikaner sind oft ausgelegt die
wahlbeteiligung niedrig zu halten
das gibt's seit dem bürgerkrieg die
wollten vor allem in den südstaaten
wofür das schwarze wohnten die
wahlbeteiligung winter hat man muss der
unterschrift muss genau seien die
adressen muss stimmen mich traurig das
sind dann so eine demokratie
man freut sich in deutschland über hohe
wahlbeteiligung aber in manchen
bundesstaaten in den usa gibt leute die
wollen die wahlbeteiligung niedrig
halten es ist deprimierend das ist nicht
gut auf warme worte viel dagegen machen
aber ich glaube trotzdem diese briefe
aus systemen es ist besonders gefordert
jetzt mit krone
das wird gut klappen die post wird
funktionieren es gibt viele geschichten
jetzt das gibt probleme
ich glaube aber nicht ich glaube diese
briefe aus system wird erfolgreich sein
wenn manche fans lief es ganz gut
das problem ist in manchen bundesstaaten
dürfen die schon vorher ziehen die
freunde zum beispiel würde am abend
ergebnisse haben aber andere
bundesstaaten die fahrenden erst am
abend die briefe zu lesen dass es dann
noch ein stück dauern wird bis das
endgültige ergebnis und stürme vor es
gibt einen bundesstaat ohio kommt
gewinnt den wahl am abend dann kann man
die briefe unter reinen hexen tagen
plötzlich verliert und schwamm könnte
vielleicht probieren zweifel in die welt
zu streuen hoffentlich nicht hoffentlich
wird es so ein klares ergebnis pro kommt
roboter gegen chance das ist nicht kommt
aber das ist eine eine befürchtung die
viele leute äußern ich muss sie an der
stelle jetzt unterbrechen oder sie sind
so wende gekommen
denn wir sind schon am ende unserer
sendung angekommen liebe zu